tropes of a-gettin screenwriter should
avoid that a more seasoned screenwriter
can navigate wow that's an interesting
question these are like very bizarre
quite I mean it's just like okay I don't
think that I don't think there are
tropes that a seasoned screenwriter are
able to navigate that sounds like that
sounds like that's like a red flag like
I'm like I'm like I don't want to do
that mommy I don't want to do tropes are
not supposed to do what I'm a baby
writer it's like it's like we need to
tell honest stuff it needs to be
original it needs to be plausible
it needs to be emotionally available it
always needs to be like that you know
that needs to happen on page 10 and it
happened that needs to happen to the
first 10 pages it needs to happen
between page 62 and 72 I mean it's all
over the script and we can't ever not
traffic in that currency you know it's
just like we don't want to we don't want
to have her be like well later you can
screw around and trick people and I mean
obviously there's things that happen
where you be you get better control but
I can't I just can't it just that
intuitively doesn't feel like that a
seasoned writers ever gonna be able to
cheat an audience in a more effective
way and they're gonna learn tricks or
something that that you know I mean
there's things with timelines and
cheating time and you know tricking an
audience in terms of moving like like
letting the audience sort of knowing the
audience like fooling around with a
calendar and being like well all this is
happening and it feels like it's
happening over a course of eight years
but it feels like it's also gonna be
happening in over a year
and there's things that are
sophisticated that happened but I think
that's like saying well and it's not a
trope though I mean that's a structure
that's just like when I started off
writing you know 25 years ago writing a
play having three people having a
conversation was confusing to me it was
like okay who's talking to who like four
people talking it was difficult and to
hear that conversation in my mind let
alone have a 150 page script which I
just wrote on
track two with four different arcs
happening in three different locations
all kind of coming like it was so
sophisticated that I never it was like
way out there that for something I never
would have been able to do something
like that even probably fifteen year ten
years ago it was too difficult I would I
still look at it ago how did you do this
like it's like it's so sophisticated in
terms of its structure keeping all the
balls in the air keeping everything
believable and clear and and and not
forgetting anybody and not crowding your
cast all those things so now I don't
know about that question that's a tricky
question I don't know I hope somebody
else can figure that out because I don't
think that there's tropes that there's
other things there probably are things
that some other teacher will be able to
answer but I I think that I don't want
to ever promise a new writer that oh
you'll be able to use tropes which are
suggests or something that's overused
you'll be able to know you'll be able to
use those later when you get more
seasoned I was like I don't want you to
ever do that I want you to always listen
to your voice right when you believe in
you know right what you really want to
write and that's what we want to give
our audiences and that's what we want to
think about is our audiences and not
like you know what what we're gonna be
able to get away with later when we know
everything or something you know so
dangerous
you